Halloa 各位同学大家晚安
正好大家同学聊到这些重要的东西
反正我就在电脑前面了
那就直接开始吧
我跟各位讲一下
我要澄清一下
有人说网路上有一位叫做Fox
他说教的是我的东西等等
我坦白說
後來我才知道原來這個是我們曾經待在群組內的一位同學
但是他離開群組已經好一段時間了
當初他進來的時間大概坦白講我也不確定大概多久
只是就短暫一段時間
那後來他出去外面怎麼教怎麼的
坦白講我都不知道
我是事後人家回來跟我講說他一直罵我的東西
我才說喔原來是這樣
我的想法就是
人家要罵就給他罵,那是他的事
我就做我的
所以到後來
大家應該會看到
基本上我不會去攻擊
任何人家做什麼
反正他愛怎麼教,就怎麼教他的事
不過他如果
擺明打著我的東西
然後去亂教
那其實坦白講,我覺得是很明確的誤導
那
旁邊這邊的同學說
被踢爆啊,怎么样这样子
今天镜头有点暗
有点暗是因为我开了这个
试试看,这样
嘿嘿嘿
我在试那个
摄影机那个什么镜头的这样
那
反正他批评就批评啊,他说他
就让他去批评他的啦
我是认为啦,我现在不是在单纯讲这位fox
好不好,我在讲给所有同学听
我认为一个在市场上面每天跟市场厮杀
每天在市场上被市场垫的trader
理论上你身上的各种锐气
很锐利很尖锐的那种感觉
应该都会被磨得干干净净才对
因为市场在垫人的时候很痛
痛到不行
所以你应该会很习惯低头
很习惯放低姿态
在市場面前他是老大
我永遠是最小的
應該是這種感覺才對
所以當我看到市場上有很多人
採取著很強勢的態度
罵別人啊等等的這種
我就站在旁邊笑一笑
我就會好吧那就讓他去吧
就大概是這種概念
所以你們應該很少看到
我們在這邊去攻擊人家去怎麼樣
他要抹黑
那他去抹黑吧
哇,他吸收了好多学生,好吧,那我也没办法
那也不是我的事,市场就是这样
而且我今天阻止的一个人,还会有千千万万个
所以有什么差呢,对吧,所以就这样子
然后另外一个Max,我也有听说,但是我也不认识
甚至这个我是完全不认识他
所以我也无从去评论人家的东西
到底怎么样,对啊
總之就
我覺得你用氣啦
用他的氣息去觀察
你在這邊上我的課
我也不會要求你去
去發誓
然後錄影
然後就抓
然後還要
好像說還去跟
跟神明開光過
還是怎麼樣
我不知道
反正我不會要你簽什麼保密協定
我全部都攤開在這邊教你了
還要簽什麼保密協定
大概
大概就是這樣
OK
那因為對我來講我的競爭對手不是他們
我的競爭對手其實就是市場
所以那我在市場上面我也
坦白講我也不需要跟他爭
我只要學會閃
學會在他很強的時候
那我就閃邊
等到他變很弱的時候
我再站出來踢他一腳
就大概是這種概念
OK
好,所以其他同學坦白講我就不知道
回答一下同學的一些問題
同學說我額頭特別亮
好啦
今天鋼鐵的數量變多
我旁邊這裡還有一隻,還有一隻這個
這個這個,還有一隻這個
看得到嗎?
好,然後我的鏡頭上面
那邊還有一隻蜘蛛人,在上面大家沒看到
OK,那我就不管不再聊別人的事情
如果同學們有一些內幕歡迎私訊給我
我也很好奇
好奇它到底交成什麼樣子
或是騙成什麼樣子我不知道
那我們來看一下
地球不會轉
這地球要大量的燈
它不用插電
它只要光源,它是太陽能的
光源就會轉
OK
好,那我來看一下前面有同學問萬海
我們看一下幾個東西
來
萬海其實這段時間還不錯啊
而且其實他前面的日線
你跟我說日線這個打底
你看喔,這個剛好跟我們今天講的很像
下來不需要接第一刀
你等他走平,再去找走平以後
然後下不去的這種邊界,再來吃都好
所以如果你說萬海這邊有一些交易機會
這個走坪後面這個地方都是我們講的打擊區
然後呢這個
這附近也還OK
所以你說吃在46.5還不錯啊
46.05
可以這個點OK喔還不錯喔
那你說預計做到51
51還不錯啊
51其實就是這一段
翻上去
同學不錯
有概念
好東西讚
再來一支,8070
你要問的是什麼?日線破底翻是否在關鍵邊緣
等一下喔,這個日線並不是破底翻喔
我塗鴉給你看,我從這邊開始塗鴉
這裡,上下上下上
請問你,眼前這張圖
我換比較粗一點的畫筆
然後換個顏色,好這樣子好了
眼前這張圖真的跟標準破底翻有像嗎?真的嗎?
好,有沒有看到底下這個角
一個高一個低,我沒有畫很精準
但是我要表達的意思有出來
有沒有看到一個高一個低
跟我們標準的破底翻
他會有一些標準的動作會是上面是平的
下面是平的
他會有這種
這種標準的東西出現
所以這個你說要破底翻
有點牽強
而且再來第二點
就算,我先講喔,就算他要刺破底翻
那也是在這個位置才對阿
怎麼會是在這個位置呢
這兩個的架差已經不一樣了喔
好不好
上面那邊,我換回細的話
這個位置已經在這個地方
所以已經不是一個好位置
這樣,OK
同學的問題蠻多,蠻長的
我盡量的快速的瀏覽過
日限吃,blablabla,54
不錯啊,預計停曆60
停損,然後呢
把剩下的出掉
OK啦,我覺得你發現他上不去出掉
我覺得沒什麼問題,你就要接受
注意你需要甘願
並且接受你自己
在這邊改變你原定的一些交易計畫
改變就改變啦,就接受就好
反正你是賺錢出場的嘛
大概就這樣子
好不好
好,然後呢
廖大叔今天好悶
真的
我今天也很悶啊
都沒有機會進場
唯一能吃的大概就下午那一瞬間
那來的太快了
我記得長榮行好像前幾天
前一段時間我才在長榮行的這裡
講說他跌到這邊是周縣的
我忘記是在哪一支影片講的
好像是是四播影片還是什麼
我那時候才在講說長榮航周線
來到這個地方
然後當大家都覺得
哇那個航空整個已經減弱了啦
怎麼樣的時候
你看他卻默默的就開始起來
所以長榮航
你剛剛問的長榮航是什麼呢
長榮航日線破底翻嗎
喔來
同學都搞錯事情喔
來
同學問破底翻的時候
同學都在
航行來到這裡才問
No no no no no
行情來到這邊已經沒有用了
他就要重新觀察了
真正能觀察破底翻的樣子
我現在一時之間找不到其他的點
所以我用之前的台積電的周線
來跟你講一個很重要的東西
包含
這個不是很標準
你必須要在
標準圖
疑似要產生的這個地方
這個邊界上
你就要在這裡
然後跟我說
老育這邊可能是破底翻喔
所以你就要在台積電的這個邊界說
可能是破底翻
這樣才對
當他長到這個地方的時候
你說老育這是破底翻
這已經過了
跟那個已經無關了
好不好
然後
3618緊碩是破底翻的標準圖嗎
等一下我先
剛剛同學問的那支股票
2618長榮航
我們再回來看一下
你說他的日線
底下降這裡有沒有很美
有,但是他接下來現階段你需要再等
要嘛等他回來
要嘛等他再上去回來測這個邊界
如果
如果是這樣子喔,注意看喔
這個邊界眼前降回來這不叫破底翻
他需要上,再回來
這時候你才能夠乖乖的塗鴉出一個
一個到這邊,然後到這邊的這種
的這種破底翻
他需要再高一點點再回來
不然現在其實不容易判斷
這樣好不好
日線
日線買在36號
是近期下不去的價格的確
那
我知道你在看的東西
因為周線
有啦周線有這個尖尖的
其實整體而已
我覺得你看的算不錯了
周線的區間大概就是像這樣子
我覺得底下這邊還算OK
還算OK啦
那已經真的盤整了好久都下不去了
這倒是OK的
要看阿里巴巴
好
不错啊
現在盤前在這邊了
這個附近如果你是用周線來看
其實周線
已經盤整好一段時間
尤其是在這附近大概79多
80這個價格
這裡其實盤整了很久
所以還不錯啦
只不過現在這個位置又是在撞牆位置
你看他在盤前的價格
撞牆區
然後小娜沒有
今天的唯一的讀點就是下午
那是我也沒有吃到的點
我給大家看一下
今天唯一的讀點就是這裡
就是這一瞬間
各位看他60分K
我把這個K放的
放這樣好了
只有在60分可以看到下沙打出尖尖的隔壁
就是這根的隔壁這附近
這附近看有沒有小刻度的標準圖
大概就只有這裡
除此之外沒有其他地方可以吃
一路噴
真的沒有辦法
好不好
我明天要去台北
對啊我明天晚上在那個台北群一起或有那個講座
所以歡迎大家來台北早晚聊天
OK
那有同學說可是位置不是很高嗎
是啊
位置很高啊所以我也沒有吃啊
一方面是下午我不在盤錢
我跑出去走走
所以一方面是我其實一直在期待
我在等這一段滿足以後
然後這邊咚咚的這樣殺下來
我一直在等
等不到
等不到就算了
所以今天就是屬於我最吃不到的行情
所以我會寬信的放掉
因為第一個我也還有長線單
我有長線的股票
早就在底下吃好了
所以這邊其實對我來講
沒有什麼關係
我賺長線的就好
對吧
短線在這個地方就不是我喜歡的點
60K的小刻度
我都是搭配5K
我的習慣就是
你看喔在短線的5K這裡
這邊有一個約略標準圖的概念
只是這個圖形在60K的滿足區
就看你要不要賭就這樣而已
那沒有什麼太多的的進場的機會那不然就是這種換,像這個如果你賭互換賭在這個我也可以給你過
因為他算是蠻長期
一個整理的平台
你賭在這個互換,你跟我說老魚
我擺明就是要賭他盤整繼續被尬出去
那這個我會給你過
這樣,OK
為什麼臉書的廖大一直在加各位好友
我跟大家宣导一下
我们正规的
我的同事
就是在我们眼见交易的廖大
他不会主动的去加你的FB
然后说加好友有LINE群
然后问你股票做的怎么样吗
我跟你说我们才懒得管你
我是很认真的讲
要不是我现在要直播
我才懒得管你的股票长什么样
No
我们根本不会花时间在你身上
好不好
我们唯一要的
就是做好自己的交易
就是这样子
所以请认明那个追踪数破万
一万人以上那个料大才是对的
然后老鱼勒
对请大家认明FB
请认明五万多粉丝的那个才是真的
这样好不好
所以
大家说都要背到大家好友
台积电的还原图
60K大顆度可不可以改看30
可以啊
我給那個Scott
你說60K可不可以改看30分K
我覺得這個完全沒有什麼問題
因為30K跟60K基本上是同一件事情
所以就你習慣就好
你看30也OK啊
你要30配5K
30配1K
OK的
但是不能這樣子看喔
不能
30也看
15也看
5分K也看
1分K也看
不能全部都看
你就會全部都亂掉
好不好
各位
有些那些外面下廣告的各種料大群組什麼的
那些全部都是假的拜託
OK
同學問Tesla
Tesla其實前一段時間已經很美了
你說周縣在關鍵邊緣嗎
關鍵邊緣坦白講
以現在來講
周縣的關鍵邊緣是在205這附近
而不是在205這附近
這才是關鍵邊緣
記得我們的說法嗎
這種邊界
這裡才是市場在乎的點
現在這個地方
現在盤前在213這裡
其實都已經有點撞牆
你可能就要再等
要嘛等它回來
要嘛就是稍微規劃一下打擊區
這邊吃少一點
這邊吃多一點
整個打擊區大框框給它框起來
如果你是用周線的格局
大概就是眼睛閉著隨便吃
大概這種概念
好不好
今天的畫面真的好暗淡
真的嗎?所以看來是我房間的燈
大家等我一下吧
我去開大燈一下
好不好
已經開始了
等我一下
好啦,回來了
那這樣子應該好多了對不對
對吧,這是我平常直播的亮度
跟我剛剛只在測試我這個攝影機的樣子
IG也都有假的啦
好啦,那我們先來看一下今天的主題
由於9點準備開始上課了
那,你說我有那個矯正的坐墊
有啊,不然沒有做這個時
我的屁股就會一直往前滑
腰就會越坐越後面
肚子就會突出來
講個好玩的事情
我們今天去一個景點
那邊有攝影師在幫忙拍照
然後呢
我跟我老婆就站在那邊
她就說那個先生
小婦說一下喔
她幫我們拍照的過程中
大概講了七八次說小婦
你知道我好受傷
你知道嗎
你知道嗎?在拍照的瞬間小步說一下
噢!好痛
好啦,來
那個,今天要聊的是這個
聊標準動作
聰明的摸,還有亂摸
這三個差異這樣
來,這個是來自於
我在Youtube上面的影片裡面
我不是有那個頻道會員的試播集有沒有
然後
中年大叔的悲哀
底下有人留言
有網友留言說
他圖看不懂
沒有標準圖當作摸
也有同學說真的看不懂
有些時候說要等回撤
有些時候說不等回撤等等
其實坦白講
我認為
尤其是底下這位網友
這位第二位網友
你可能沒有完全
好好的看過我們的這些影片
如果你有慢慢這樣看過來
其實你會發現
其實我們在做的事情都一樣
好不好
來 我們來好好的講一下
底下有位網友幫我平反一下
上個月有一樣的疑問
多看幾部直播
我們先來看一下這張圖
我把這些留言都先關掉
大家看一下這張
這張圖
有一個同學摸在這
這不是我的單
這是我在檢討
某一個同學丟出來的單子
我在幫他調整的過程
我跟他說
喔 這是一個好單
我說這是聰明的摸
好 那同學就會說
老鱼你不是常常跟我說
這麼兇的大K棒
不要摸
對嗎 你自己還有叫IG的小編
寫那個很兇的K棒不要亂摸
但是人家這樣摸
你居然說到好單
啊 雙標啊
好不好
你先放在心上喔
等一下我們會開始慢慢講解
為什麼會有這些差異
這張圖我先擺旁邊
好 來囉
然后下面同一个留言里面
又有人说老鱼你在9分45秒
是因为数据的关系
老鱼教人不要赌数据
却说那一根可以
根本双重标准
注意哦
我说不要赌数据的方式是这样子
不要事先去猜
例如说飞浓
你不要去猜它
这一次会是大涨还是大跌
还是它预期可能会是高于预期
低于预期
然后说也会怎么样
都不用拆
你亲眼看着它公布以后的样子
市场会说话
所以你都不需要用你的脑袋去说话
用眼睛就好了
然后第二种是
不要在数据公布的瞬间
那一瞬间那个跳动的幅度
那个跳动的幅度
很恐怖
波动超大
我不知道大家有没有在那一瞬间赌过
我不喜欢风险是
是我无法控制的事情
但是在数据公布的那一秒钟
那个风险是我完全掌握不到
就算我有设停损
那个停损可能会在这边触发
然后触发了以后
在下面一百点以外才被执行
中间都中空的嘛
跳很快
我怎么知道
然后你去跟券商讲
券商只会说
我们是正常的执行
这是市场自然的滑架
滑你妈滑那么远
对吧
我以前就曾經被這種給
給掃蕩過很多次
所以到後來我才說瞬間你不要去吃
但是那個瞬間過了以後
可不可以
甚至我常常這樣子
我舉個例子
如果
如果是待會有數據要公布
假設我今天小娜讓我吃在這邊
好不好
各位假裝一下
小娜讓我吃在這邊
我已经有很大一大段
我有很大一段的获利
在帮我保护我的部位
就算这瞬间要公布数据
OK啊给他
反正我已经有一大段
我的成本在这里
对吧
然后我会设一个稍微上来一点点的停顺
以防滑架再滑下来
对不对
总之我的
我已经站在几乎不会赔钱的这个角度了
读读看啊
懂这种感觉吗
我是只有这种情形下我才会做
那如果是例如说待会即将要公布任何一个数据
再好的点我看到数据要公布我就会先闪
包含跟待会美国九点半要开盘一样
那要开盘其实对我来讲也等于是数据公布的概念
如果我的成本在很远我就读读看
如果我的成本在附近先闪
如果都还没有下单那就等一下再下单
就大概是这个概念
OK
有同学第一次来看直播
欢迎
好来继续
来这张图
是我用手画的图
所以画的图没有很标准
但是我只是要讲这个概念
等一下我们会带各种图形
眼前真实的行情来讲
什么叫做乱摸
什么叫聪明摸
什么叫标准图的出手
注意看这张图
这张图这里
我说这个是乱摸
什么叫乱摸
我们从乱摸来讲
假设
来
假设你是在今天
一路上来这个地方
在这里
没有任何参考点的情形下
在这里直接做空单
你在这里
在这一根里面
你打任何的空单
没有参考点
这个叫做乱摸
这个会被我揍
对吧
这种
例如说这个
跌破低点
跌破低点一路下杀
一路下杀的过程中
这里都没有任何参考点
你说有啊老玉
这里啊
这也太远了一点吧
如果照这样讲
你不就假设行情一路从这边杀到这里
你不就每一个都可以往左边对
这里有支撑
你要支撑到哪里去啊
照你这样讲
每一条线都是支撑
对吧
我曾经看过一个网友
他会在市场上画行情
他会画各种支撑线
就是这里是支撑
这里是支撑
然后他也出来教
他就说
他就画好多密密麻麻的线
然后呢
他说如果跌破这根
就会来到这根
这不是废话吗
你画的线那么多
那如果
如果这根下不去
就会往上来到这根
废话
这样我也会
对吧
这还不简单
你画五条五线谱
没关系我有十线谱
我有二十线谱
看谁比较厉害
对不对
所以不能这样子
注意听我讲
如果有刚刚的案例
刚刚这个下杀的案例
下杀
这里有个口诀给大家
下杀第一次到第二次
它才会找到一个边界
两点才能连成一线
两点一线
这个口诀你拿回去用
而且这个两点的概念是要两次
第一次只是下杀
它需要第二次
再由上往下来到这个地方
这概念跟前面很像
来
第一次下杀
第二次下杀
这个叫做两点一线
你至少要这样才画得出边界
对吗这个才有边界
OK
所以如果你是说在
如果你是说
在这种下跌的时候
你说老鱼我要摸这个
这里做多对过来没东西
做多对过来没东西
做多没东西没东西没东西没东西
反正这一串里面
你做任何的多单都会被我揍
因为它左边对过来是
你自己看嘛
是不是空空的什么东西都没有
这个叫做乱摸
OK?好
下沙找很多邊界
什麼?
你朋友去上FOX的客交的
下沙然後直接掛單
然後GG
好啦
說真的如果詐騙去洗一個無腕的粉絲團
我跟你說
要辨認賈老魚的好方法
你就問他
老魚優雅是誰
你就打那个优雅
你看他会不会跟你开车
会开车的就是真的老鱼
这样应该就OK了
好不好
我不要乱开车
要被老婆骂
来
靠我要讲什么
我已经忘记了
我要讲这个
来来来
什么叫两点一线
看一下我的图
我的图
来
聪明的摸
聪明的摸不代表
是标准动作
聪明的摸就代表市场来到这个边界
它已经在一个范围内
走出一个叮咚叮咚叮咚的这个区间
走出这种区间来
然后呢在这个区间来有个重点
这时候我再把刚刚这张图拉回来
来各位请仔细看一下这张图
这个边界你这边画一条线对过来
你能看到一个点
两个点
而且这个第二个点
你视觉上面应该能够第一时间翻一个小亚当下来
我应该没有讲错
对吧
它从时间满足了几件事情
第一个是大颗度的边界
Check
第二个小颗度满足区
有没有标准图
没有图
有没有惯性
也没有惯性
它单纯就只是尖尖的隔壁摸
对吧
但是这种摸已经比起这个叫做聪明摸这个叫做乱摸同样尖尖的有没有隔壁的那个其实已经好很多了比起第一个
各位有知道差异吗
有没有
所以我是站在这个角度去跟他讲说
哦,这样子
也可以吃的
旁边大家聊的那些人
我没有一个认识
所以各位不要引导我
我不认识你们旁边聊的这些人
OK
你们可以去问贾老鱼
问他这个认识
我都不认识
好
好来
然后再来
什么叫做标准图
注意看
同样的东西
一模一样的东西
这个
这个东西
发生在这里
同样的东西
这个就是我们标准动作的进场点
为什么是标准动作
来我画图给大家看
来咯
下 上 下 上 下 上
有没有看到一个标准图的图形
有看到吗
这就是我们讲的标准动作
那偶尔在这个地方
就会直接咚咚咚咚咚就上去了
然后上去后再回来
打出一个真正的标准图的点
也会哦
这蛮常见的
偶尔会这样子
那偶尔吃了以后就棒就把你打掉
对吧
那这有没有关系
没有关系
那为什么我会强调说
大黑K不要吃
但是那个同学
这么大根的K棒
我还允许他吃
第一个
同学的
他现在的状态
我看他的单子好一段时间了
我知道他目前的灰棒
还不至于乱掉
所以我会开放一些权限给他
你偶尔要偷摸一下
一天出手歌
一两次是偷摸的单子
我觉得OK啦
无伤大雅
你就算摸錯了,你會陪到哪裡去嗎?
不會!但是你要注意,不能一直摸
這個就是大部分的人收不回來的地方
這樣,好不好?
然後再來,還有喔
有人說,底下這個尖尖的可不可以吃?
這個尖尖的吃,除非是這種大顆度滿足虛
這裡,這個,才比較適合
不然這個我不建議同學吃
那如果你是前面已經有賺錢
你是在拿你赚来的钱里面的一部分的零钱拿出来当子弹
拿来打这些很赌很赌的单子
这我给过
因为这个本质上也就是另外一个乱摸
他也是乱摸
这个对吧
但是这个情形下
这种乱摸
这个这个这个乱摸
只有在有钱可以乱花的情形下在玩
再玩啊如果你画错
这边一下单发现我乱摸错了
好回到正常动作
就不要再让自己
进入到那个状况状态下
我也会乱摸啊
记不记得我上礼拜还是上上礼拜直播
我不是亲自乱给大家看吗
好像就上礼拜而已
对吧我上礼拜就是一大堆
这种单子我自己都知道
我明明说不能做
这就是上礼拜的图上礼拜一路下来
底下平的这样子
我就是在这种图里面乱摸这样
这就是我失败的原因
上礼拜
这样
好不好
后面还有哦
来
这是一张某个
某个同学打出来的单子
Jack说好球
那各位看一下同学这张单子
来我放大一点给大家看好
来
放大一点
这张单子
你看它是不是打在一个
一个显而易见的边界上
有看到这件事吗
市场从这边
咚咚咚来到这边
整理了好多次
所以这边的单子
已经不是第一刀
第一刀在这边
子弹射过来
这个人跟这个人
接了第一刀
所以这两个人中枪了
有没有
我们呢
是躲在人家后面
而且这个同学还蛮聪明的
他躲在尖尖的
尖尖的隔壁
好我问各位
这边有没有标准图
这边其实也没有标准图
我涂鸦不出来
但是这边是不是一个好的下单点
是
老玉没有标准图
你居然说这单是好单
就可以说是好单
因为打到最后
各位这句话请记起来
交易到最后
所有的动作都是摸
这边摸摸那边摸摸
那是到最后的事情
这样
但是一开始我们得需要
需要建立一些一些很基础的标准动作
先有框架
那在这个框架下
你先练习一段时间
把基本动作给扎稳
然后这时候你再开始把框架一个个拿掉
因为到后来你的交易会已经变成是
就是单纯就是看价格
这样了解这个想法吗
好再来下一张
这张也不是我的单子
后面有我的这张不是我的
这是另外一个某个同学的单子
来各位看一下同学的单子
它根本就是在做标准动作
各位看它这单
尖尖的隔壁
有没有看到
这是不是两条线的边界
尖尖的打破隔壁
有没有看到这件事
所以在这边出手
被这个点掉了
在这个地方出手
它的第一单这个出手
就是一个好的边界乱打2
我们的边界2就是这样子
当你能够画出两条线
跌破尖尖的隔壁
蹦 持下去就对了
这就是我们的边界2的练习
所以你偶尔可以利用边界2
偶尔可以用边界四的标准图
所以进入到自由打单的领域的时候
我不会给大家一些很严格的框架
因为你已经照顺序的这样
咚咚咚咚咚咚练过来了
我需要让你放开一点
不然你会把自己绑死
那这段放开的时候就发现
有些同学喜欢打完成
打很棒的标准图
有些同学喜欢打这种边界二
但是他也是有道理的
合理的摸哦
也不是接刀了
也不是下杀第一个乱摸了
有没有
那我会根据同学的状况
去给他们一些权限
你可以稍微开放一点
没关系
你打太多
你太外放了
收一点进来
那这就是我们的责任
去帮同学调到一个
比较适合他的东西
我不希望
也不可能让大家都变成一模一样
每个人总是有不同的时间
我讲时间是指
你一天的free time
你可以交易的时间不一样
你有空的时间不同
你的个性也不同
对吧
甚至你交易的商品
什么全部都不同
大家的资金水位也都不同
对吧
那我不可能要求大家做同一件事
但是我们可以在同一个大的基本动作下
签订
然后慢慢慢慢再根据自己的习惯
你喜欢做短线
你喜欢做长线
这都可以
这样OK吗
来再来
那这个
后面这边这些单子
这单也是好单
所以它其实
这边做的事情跟这边做的事情
是同一件事
这个我都会给过
但是通常哦
注意看哦
我给过的还有另外一个点是
它这个是五分K
它是一个从这边整理到这边
这么长的六十分K的整理区间
所以照道理讲
跌破这一整段
来这么多整理的
卡住这么多人
照道理讲有没有跌破
跌破了应该要发生什么事
跌破了应该要东东
把这边所有的停损
全部逼出来
逼在下半段这里
该发生却没发生
有没有
这就是我们常常在讲的
然后你找出那个关门放狗的
那个干净边缘
大概就是这样
OK
好再来
这是我的单子
前两天的单子
我在10月31号的晚上
然后这天我在
白天我其实没有做什么单子
然后我记得有一单是停损
一单是不赔
大概这样再更前面一点
注意看一下我的单子
来前面这个
我这个是五分K
但是我的前面这一单
这一单我不是打五分K的单
前面这单是我打一分K的单子
所以这个在一分K里面
有东西躲后面
所以5K看起来
会是
没有任何参考点的
直接偷摸
但是1K有东西
你想象一下这里的1K
第一个K棒下来
隔壁再下来
我其实就是在这个的里面
应用了边界乱打2的这个概念
尖尖的隔壁
我就是这样做这件事情
然后呢
后面这几单
我昨天那天其实蛮多同学都打到
打到这里
你知道我会醒过来就是因为
刚好把我点不赔的这单
这个有个长下引线
这个长下引线的隔壁
这里让我醒过来
为什么
因为各位注意
我们的破底翻是不是长这样子的图形
那这边
下上
我是不是可以约略的
在差不多的区域
画出
好像可以有破底翻的样子
所以我的吃單
我是在這一根的之後
這一根他界定出
這個區域是有人用的
所以我的揮棒區域
我的邊界我想好了
我就是拿這個地方當我的防守
這一根拿他當我的防守
所以在這邊吃一單
沒有破晃晃晃
好這邊再補一個
我原本就要吃的部位
然後出去了
出去了這邊
這個地方我先出掉一個部位
另外一个单子留着
后来这边我记得当天我好像
哇旁边这边有忘记截图
这样看不知道看不看得到
啊好好总之后面就是
来到这边我直接把这单
然后跟加码的单子我就一起出在这个地方
我说累了要睡觉了
后面发生什么事我就不管了
反正我就出一出就这样子
各位看一下哦
我有没有吃在破底番即将成型的这个地方
所以我其实就是在赌
但是我的赌是有道理的
因为我等价格怎么样
弯回来
并且由上而下去测试刚刚测试的这个边界
这样有人可以理解我讲的概念吗
所以在这里
在这里同学说这张有小格局的破底番
没错
这张有
在我们的脑袋里面
因为我们看破底翻看
很多了
就我打的这张并不是
并不是很准
很准的标准动作
因为我要求同学打的标准动作是
不能去摸下眼线的最边界
有人说交易到最后
就靠感觉吗
某个程度来讲
是
但是这个盘感
并不是莫名其妙
没有任何参考依据的盘感
这个盘感是
你根据一模一样的辨认
看久了
你得出来的一个盘感
我就问你
你看你家亲戚的小孩
你哥哥的小孩
姐姐的小孩
你去看一下
你是不是远远一看
这跟他妈很像
他的眼睛跟他爸很像
他有他妈妈的鼻子
他爸爸的嘴巴
有没有
为什么
因为你看这些亲戚
看很多很多遍了
所以你是
注意哦
盘感这件事情
是可以训练
而且这个训练是
你要事先有一个
很明确的框架
我告诉你
就是这个图形
你就一直看
一直看
这个图形看久了
你会在市场上面
我用现在的小纳
来我们来证明一些事情
我们来证明一些事情
我知道这边下不去
但是我也没有打算下单
因为它的位置不对
如果待会来到这个地方
如果喜欢做空的同学
这边就会是你在乎的点
我可以先做好计划
对吧
而且眼前行情来到这边
我怎么看我都知道
这边就不要再继续往上做了
再五分钟每股就要开盘
对吧
所以其实你说
大量的肌肉训练
没错就是那个视觉的肌肉
脑袋中的印象
也是这样啊
你知道吗
语言的训练
英文日文的任何训练
不就是这样吗
你就是先
在你不知道英文的任何一个单字
你没有给它意义
例如说我今天给一个单字
Apple
如果我没有让你知道它的发音
你在听到人家讲英文的里面
就算人家讲到Apple
你也不知道是什么东西
因为你从头到尾都不知道它的发音
你根本就捕捉不到
但是一旦你发音建立在你的资料库里面
那个音波的样子
你的脑袋资料库有了
你下一次听到有人讲Apple的时候
你第一秒就对耶
苹果
所以是这样子的模式
这样OK
所以是真的可以训练
而且训练到后来会慢慢变成直觉
这个我没有办法去完全的教给你
但是我可以给你训练的方式
我們都是這樣過來的
好不好
這是另外一位同學
他在我的留言底下說
他也有吃
他吃的點是吃在這裡
而且當時我跟廖大我們在開線上會議
然後我一開完線上會議
我正好加碼了
然後我就立刻敲廖大我就敲他說348對吧這個位置就是這裡這就是我加碼的位置我加碼在1K裡面啦那其實在5K裡面就會長這樣子
概念是很像的
所以廖大就很明確
他就說太準了
我一看就知道他會做在哪裡啊
對吧
有人說多看優雅日文就會好
錯了你日文根本就不會好
那需要用到什麼日文
對不對
按日文讲来讲去不就
我还是不要乱讲好了
总之同学也打出一样的单子
这是不是也是互换
同学也是在躲后面
所以这单有点摸
有
但是算不算是值得摸
还可以
而且我大概知道他在干嘛
然后他一天也没有下很多单子
给他过
有没有
我后面还有东西要讲的
这是
但是我前
在更前一天
10月30号
我记得我还有发现洞
我在这边打了这一单
这一单的前面
很多同学问说老鱼
这里不是撞墙吗
60分K
他的大压力在这边
我一大早就知道60K撞墙
我直接开真实行情好了
在更前面
在这里
我当时在这边打了这一单
这一单就是刚刚在
就是这一单
那這一單
我打的時候
我一早就知道說撞這個牆
但是我也知道它跳空上來
來了一個尖尖的
所以這兩根K棒
幫助我定義出了
這個邊界好像可以用
所以你看一下
我吃單的時候
是不是就是這樣子
就是這個我吃在
我並沒有接刀
我也沒有追高
注意看
追高的人是吃在這
這叫追高
這會被我打
不行
吃在底下這邊
這是接刀
這也不行
我是吃在人家下來了
我還依稀
可以看到一個小小的
破底翻的概念
那我在這一天
我早上就說
我有兩套計畫
一套就直接堵
堵底下套牢的人
被嘎上去
蹦蹦上去
這是其中一個
對吧
另外一套計畫就是
這邊如果把我跌下來
把我停损掉了
最好跌破这边
然后把这一段带下来
把这个缺口封起来
我在这边等你
我就看你哪一套计划会来嘛
结果第一套计划就上去了
就上去了
这样
懂吗
所以你看我在做的事情
是不是你这样一路看过来
发现我几乎都在做同一件事
可能只是刻度的不同
让你以为我在接刀
但是实际上我们接的都是有道理的
都是有躲在后面
甚至是有
第一只脚
第二只脚破了才吃
有没有看到这个是很大的重点
两只脚
而且这个脚的重点是
你不能这样子不能说
这里是下面然后上去后
这样子不行
我要它再一个这样子
破了这才是我的
OK
好
来
模拟单
你有打在后面下
然后我跟大家讲
我底下这里插一个tick
我后来有去看
我的这个停损设定好以后
就是成本价
我就没有动
底下这里插一个tick
然后就把它打掉
真的是笑死了
好不好
有人突然就问我对黄金的看法
好来
就用黄金
我们来看一下黄金
我现在怎么看黄金
對黃金線的看法嗎
一秒鐘
我不喜歡在這邊做多
你要做你做
但是我不喜歡做
這不是我會喜歡做多的地方
那如果短線呢
短線
這個短線好美喔
你自己看
不該上去的邊界
下不去又變上不去
剛剛就剛剛在這裡
所以你說邊界有沒有用
就剛剛這裡
这一大堆就是上不去啊
你看就是上不去啊
对吧
所以你问我怎么样啊
来这边这段咚咚
怎么样看都我都不会在这边继续往那里做
好不好
后面怎么样也不关我的事
因为我不做空嘛
所以如果我是做黄金的人
我早就把我的获利抛掉了
别人要做这个烫手山芋
给人家
我已经先吃饱了
后面可能还有一些东西可以吃
就留给人家吃
我不要了
大概就是这种概念
OK
来
后面还有
这边带一些观念
我大概还要再十分钟吧
我说事实上
我的确双重标准
为什么我会这样讲
我对不同的同学
其实是用着不同的标准
你看眼前这个人
这个人是谁
这个人歪着身体
用一只手打球
他都可以打得比我好
这大骨祥品
这张图是我找到老半天
找到他被删證的画面
但是你有没有看到
大骨香瓶他怎么打都可以打得很好
就算弯着腰这样乱打
都可以打全力打
对吧
这个男人太狠了
太狠的原因是因为
他的打击热区
他的打击热区有这么大
每一格都三成以上
甚至有四成多
你就不要高久被他逮到
对吧
都三成多
这是他的打击热区
我咧
我也有我的打击热区
我的热区在这边
对打击率可能只有一成
有没有
这是我老鱼的热区
跟大骨的热区
对吧
好
那所以
同一套训练
例如说大骨每天的训练的方式
我去练有没有用
我现在去练那个
绝对没有用
为什么
因为大骨已经度过了
最初階的这个阶段
他在高中以前早就都练好了
对吧
我现在42岁了
什么都还不会才刚开始
所以我们两个的训练的
训练的强度
或是训练的方法绝对不一样
对吧
那所以
我会教很多新手同学
你去乖乖的打
标准动作就好了
标准动作练熟了
你要怎么变形
那是后面的事情
大方向大格局都一样就好
所以我会说
基本功不外乎是这些
来我这边讲给大家听
这是我很早以前写的东西
不外乎是这些
两条线翻卡当
涂鸦
识别
三问
交易计划的建立
然后进场呢
也要练习
所以这是基本功
叫做观念
进场就是出手
边界乱打一
边界乱打二
大概就是
打棒球
踢吧
球放在那边
然后不动
你慢慢去打他
然后一路这样子练
惯性回来加尖尖的吃
然后区间的吃法等等
出场练习
出场也要练啊
持仓的心态也要练啊
空手的心态也要练啊
像今天我就空手啊
对吧
所以所有的这些
每一个东西都需要练
你要去习惯这整件事情
甚至是习惯
亏损以后的危机处理
每个人都会遇到亏损
但是遇到亏损以后
你是被亏损给吸进去
还是你是遇到亏损
你能够很坦然的去面对亏损
这两个人的结局就会不一样
那在没有经过训练以前
每个人都会被吸进去
所以我们的责任
我们的角色就是在告诉大家
你可以透过练习
让自己习惯
享受亏损
享受哦
享受亏损这件事
这很违反人性
所以才不容易做到
OK
这是我在YouTube上看到的
我在台南Jush的
话说Jush真的很厉害
他不要乱支持球队
这是一个职棒球员
陈瑞昌
他在教小朋友们
教高中同学打棒球
他说练习小手臂击球的时候
脚跟腰都不要转
打棒球怎么可能腰跟脚不转
不就是要用腰的力量跟脚的力量出去吗
他干嘛叫人家腰跟脚都不要转
因为他把一个完整的挥棒流程
拆开来变成分解动作
然后一次就练一个小动作
一个小动作
就每次就练一个
到最后再把这些小动作拼
全部像拼图一样拼起来
结合一起综合练习
是这样对吧
有没有说两个黑人教练
没有啦
我可以讲打棒球的都会晒很黑
我收回
那个小可爱一点都不黑
所以我要讲的概念就是
教义
它其实就是把一个很复杂的动作
全部拆开来
但是你不能单独从
其中一个小动作
就去看整件事情
如果你站在棒球场上
真正的正式比赛
挥棒的时候
你的腰跟屁股没有转
你会被教练打死
对不对
他说你干嘛
只用手臂打
手臂最弱
干嘛用手臂打
然后你说
但是陈瑞昌教练这样教
他教我只要用手臂
屁股跟腰先都不要转
他说的
你看他自己讲的
对不对
这是这样吗
你不能拿中间的练习的阶段
拿出来直接上场打击
你需要把拼图先拼起来
然后再去用全貌的方式
上场打击
这样才OK
这样好不好
所以很多同学会误会我们的交易
因为可能同学只是看了某一支影片
然后在这影片里面的某个观念
这样子
结果同学就误会了
误会了说原来这样子可以做
或是这样不能做
老鱼你说这样不行
那又可以
因为一支影片毕竟就一支影片
也不过就像这样子
一个小时而已了不起
对吧
那所有的交易全貌
并没有完全看到
好不好
所以不要太快的去下定论
这样
OK
所以其实今天全部的讲法
我到重点的那一章给大家
重点的那一章
在这里
这些除了这个乱摸以外
这个不行以外
其实聪明的摸可以
标准破离翻也可以
但是新手同学
只能先练这个
练这个练到某个程度
我会让你再练这个
这样
然后这两个都练过了
像这个其实就是边界乱打二在练的事情
这两个都练过了
等你到自由打单的时候
你就可以让自己
自由的在
自由的状况下
你去抉择说
这里我要用哪一套方式
我是要拿短棒触及呢
还是我是要打
我是要打全力打的方式打呢
还是要怎么样
你可以自己决定
那有个重点
提醒大家
像这种摸
如果行情掉下去以后
最忌讳的就是
就是这样
这里再一个下引线
稍微低一点点
再摸一次
又被停损
下引线
又摸一次
下影线又摸一次
然后你会发现
你是沿着一个斜斜的角度
一路摸一路摸
这样不行
一个真正的好的摸
你必须要建立在一个水平的边界上
这个水平的边界
如果变成斜斜的下来了
这就跟你当初在想的东西
已经完全不一样了
这个就要注意
这样好不好
好
这张可以出桌垫吗
我画那么丑
你要桌垫
不要啦
你自己画就好了
我画得很丑
好不好
好了
各位
这边请大家跟我一起念念这一段
每天都是好棒的一天
会有好事发生在你我身上
我会尽力帮助身边的人
让他们过得更好
好不好
这个想法请你每天早上
中午晚上照三餐的这样子
好好的念
这样OK
好好的念过去
然后身上直接把它执行出来
我相信你的生活真的会
因为你这个念头的改变而变得更好
好不好
有同学说
这个课程应该学得再来看直播吗
我的直播
坦白讲直播就是
因为是直播嘛
所以它比较像是东一块西一块拼图
那我在Yota上的那套课程是
我至少前面的拼图
可能前半部的拼图
我是有系列的帮你拼起来了
但是拼起来这些拼图
你这样还不够
你看完那些以后
再回来看这些直播
会帮你把后半段的拼图再补起来
这样会比较好
前面那边的确是有系列的
不过里面的观念我先讲
我每一个观念其实都在免费的直播都讲过
所以如果你有时间
你要慢慢看也可以
就不用花钱买
这样好不好
它有点就像是精选级的概念
这样OK
好
那今天就到这边
好不好
新同学们
来
请先把YouTube的
这一年份的
由新的往旧的看
看一年就够了
更旧的不用看了
因为我的主题
一直都重复
我讲来讲去
都讲一样的东西
这样
OK
好
那我们的今天
就到这边结束了
各位拜拜